Oh yeah!
Check you out, Davy Deals.
Oh my gosh, dude.
My latest toy.
This is yours?
I buy them and drive them!
- This is really yours?
- Yeah.
I mean, I know--
come here.
How are you, brother man?
Good to see you, Davy.
I mean, I know you were
looking for a muscle car,
but this thing is
actually super cool now.
It's a Falcon.
'69 Falcon, Ford.
'69?
Bro, I'm shocked right now.
NARRATOR: Ford debuted the
small, economic Falcon in 1959
for the 1960 model year as a
response to a growing recession
and the immense popularity
of cheap imports
like the Volkswagen Beetle,
and it immediately began
outselling the competition.
Ford beat them to the punch
when it came to naming, as well.
Unknown to each other,
both Ford and Chrysler
were developing small
cars to be named Falcons,
but Ford registered the
name with the Automobile
Manufacturers Association just
20 minutes ahead of Chrysler,
winning the naming rights.
The Falcon platform
would eventually
evolve into the first
generation Ford Mustang.
This is a great
looking car, man.
I was shooting for a
GTO, but got the Ford.
Well, you know, I'm an
equal opportunity guy.
You know how much I
love old Fords as well,
and this is basically
a Mustang under here.
Right.
Pretty cool, huh?
It's tough.
What's under the
hood of this baby?
It's 351 Windsor.
Kind of hit it, pick.
Oh, dude.
It's Cobra, so they
built it out to a 408.
Stroke it out.
Yeah, so it's
got some high RPM.
This is very
clean and very cool.
I love the install
and I love the hood.
I love the scoop.
What's the tranny?
The trannys a C4 Ford.
Boom.
- Nice.
It's a light little car, too.
Oh, dude, they
don't weigh anything.
They don't weight
nothing for the horsepower
that this thing is putting out.
What's the chances of taking
me for a ride at this rate?
- Let's go.
- Really?
Let's get the
live lock lit up.
Really?
Yeah it's got
a full live lock.
I wanna go for a ride.
All right, hop in.
Cool.
There we go.
You know what's really
impressive about this car?
How solid it is.
There's no rattles, there's no
squeaks, there's no nothing.
Rock solid.
And for a hot rod?
Come on, man.
This thing moves.
Hang a right here at
the barbecue joint.
Yeah!
My man Davy Deals, he
knows how to pick 'em, man.
And driving around in this baby
has definitely cleared my head.
This is all about the fun.
NARRATOR: Now it's time
to get back to the shop
and get back to work.